my favorite line is  i'm going to bed before either of you  come up with another clever idea to get  us killed or worse expelled i'm going to  bed before either of you come up with  another clever idea to get us killed or  worse expelled  i said bloody a lot no i always got a  thrill from saying bloody bloody hell  bloody hell bloody hell was that all  about my father will hear about this my  father will hear about this why is it  always me why is it always me good luck  to harry good luck i appear as a ghost  on the station platform  and i say harry  harry  i can touch you now i can  touch you  honestly woman you call yourself our  mother honestly woman you call yourself  our mother morning  morning  [Music]